pour marcel fontaine marcel carton et
jean paul kauffmann et pour tous ceux
qui négocier leur libération la dernière
ligne droite a été jalonné d'échecs et
aussi de rebondissements retentissant
souvenez vous par exemple du
détournement d'avion déco et r'ways le
détournement est intervenue au moment
précis où l'on était pratiquement pour
acquise la libération des otages hervé
brusini la crau l'imprévu le voilà ce
boeing déco et airlines immobilisé sur
l'aéroport d'alger
c'était à la mi avril une trentaine de
passagers et un commando qui réclame la
libération de dix sept extrémistes
chiites détenus au koweit
la mécanique de la négociation sur les
otages français est bloqué ceux qui
tiennent cet avion appartiennent à la
même mouvance que les ravisseurs de
cartons fontaine et kaufman 20 avril la
médiation algérienne dénoue la crise et
deux jours plus tard un falcon 50 se
pose sur l'aéroport de larnaca à son
bord les émissaires français parmi eux
jean charles marchiani
voici la seule image de cet homme de
l'ombre ce businessman ancien lieutenant
du contre espionnage français au passé
tumultueux il était en liaison
permanente avec charles pasqua lors
conversation téléphonique se faisait en
langue corse
mais ce jour là le voyage de retour a eu
lieu sans les otages
un revirement cauet tient dans des
promesses faites sur l'allègement des
peines des 17 détenus en est peut être
la raison
autre en mots clés du dossier otages
iskandar safa chrétiens libanais homme
d'affaires ami du président syrien
il serait l'un des banquiers de l'iran à
beyrouth peut-être est-ce là me saluer
par jacques chirac dans sa déclaration
et qui sait le nombre d'actions à la
ville connaissait employés nous en
parler un petit peu
non c'est bien il était bien dans cet
effet simplement sans pourquoi que
j'avais à céder c'était l'ami de la
france
comme mon groupe beaucoup de chrétiens
libanais alors disons nos fournisseurs
que leur seconde patrie à la france et
ils font pas fort pour la france des
choses que d'autres ne font pas eh bien
écoutez je pense que vous avez presque
tout dit je dirais simplement que je
n'ai pas dit qu'il s'agissait de lui
vous inscrire à cette affaire j'ai
simplement dit qu'elles étaient ses
qualités mais je ne sais pas si c'est un
mythe l'iran l'algérie on sait a
également facilité pour des raisons
humanitaires le règlement des dernières
opérations de cette libération
mais ce qui a provoqué l'accélération
dénouement reste encore pour l'instant
une énigme